hey guys a little bit out of breath to
find up about one kilometer at least
several hundred meters I'm on top of a
small mountain it's probably just a big
hill but it was a little bit strenuous
especially after playing several hours
of chess behind me you can see pretty
much the whole town of an auskey it's a
very small town
there should be sky in the background
there's sky hello to the first commenter
Lolo use de man thanks for watching this
is probably not going to be a live
stream or a long livestream but I just
wanted to say hi to people hello Tyler
hello kronole dino a interesting name
I was playing chess a few hours ago I
had a relatively quick game and by
relatively quick I mean like two and a
half three hours loving this non chess
content this is slightly non chess but
slightly chess I'll probably still talk
about just a little bit
hello Nika Nika is new here good to see
you Nika Casey chaos sports hello tile
MCN good to see you on YouTube yeah this
is my second ever YouTube livestream
I did one the other day while kayaking
and it's very hard to livestream in
kayak at the same time hello SF Glen
thanks for watching
so yeah I just wanted to do a quick
check-in there's bugs all around me even
though I put bug spray on about half
hour ago
I just finished round was it around
eight it's a ten round tournament
I'm having a pretty disappointing events
given the game that I played yesterday
if people want to see game updates you
can check out Coast yaakov Itsuki's
YouTube channel just type his name in
youtube and you should find the videos I
have a 104 move loss yesterday I was
pushing for a win with two rooks and two
pawns for a queen and then I hung a rook
and
to lose and it was pretty sad but that's
life and that's the nature of chess it
can be brutal sometimes the nice thing
about losing a game an environment like
this is that it's it's it's beautiful
here
mountains are it's just amazing scenery
fun the setting over the mountains I
know people can see this something is
already not visible but the clouds are
cool actually right over there there's
some strays light is really cool
pictures with my my professional camera
which people can see on Instagram just
Eric Rosen photography and I've been
posting a lot of lot of mountain photos
with cool skies anyway not sure what
else to talk about the tournament wraps
up in a couple more days and then I'm
off to Prague I'll be there for about a
week to ten days not necessarily for
chess even though there is a chess event
going on there I'll probably play like a
little side event or something so stay
tuned for that I'll probably try and do
some some other type of content in
Prague there's not gonna be mountains
but there's gonna be some nice
architecture probably some nice food too
so yeah I think I'm gonna wrap it up I
would encourage people if you want to
watch some exciting chess contents you
can check out the st. Louis chess club
YouTube channel the the u.s. junior
tournament is going on right now with
some great coverage bye-bye Tata and
Robert Hess I just saw someone asked me
me my score I can't see like the
messages keep disappearing I'm not doing
that well I think I have five out of
eight points I've lost to two GM's and I
lost to a 2,200 yesterday so I'm
performing a little bit below my rating
panda Panda he's playing the London
that's awesome
I just came out with a course on the
London which I've been mentioning a lot
recently for HS net
if you go to my Twitter you can probably
find a link to the course there is
actually a game in the London today
between Andrew tang and a wonder Liang
Andrews playing the London's whites and
it looked like a really interesting
position last time it looked they were
just how the opening Andrew traded off
his dark squared Bishop to get these
double F pawns but looks like he has
some King side attack
kronole Dino says come to Croatia
Croatia is probably crazy right now give
him a World Cup situation I do want to
come to crib
hello but now I'm back I'm at dinner I
don't know how to see the chat because
it keeps disappearing live chat oh
here's the chat someone is asking if I
have a chessboard now I do not have a
chessboard I just have my camera and my
sunglasses but yeah this is not
necessarily a chess stream so anyway I'm
gonna wrap it up yes someday I'll
challenge agony there maybe once my
audience grows a bit more maybe once I
hit 10k I'll do like a nagging Mater
match or something if he's down for it
anyway if you guys want to enjoy the
view one last time yeah this is Spain
I'll see you guys in the future